Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Vi ricorderete [che] qualche settimana fa,
mi sembra la settimana scorsa,
molti giornali del mondo
sono usciti con grandi titoli:
cambiamento climatico, siamo prossimi
ad un punto di non ritorno.
Io vivo in India,
e anche i giornali indiani
riportavano questa notizia.
Mi è sembrata un'introduzione ideale
a quello di cui volevo parlare oggi,
che appunto riguarda i cinque grandi
problemi globali di questo pianeta
che sono l'acqua,
la fame e la malnutrizione,
la povertà, la biodiversità
e il cambiamento climatico.
Si parla di questi problemi
come se fossero indipendenti;
in realtà a me piace pensare
che siano tutti in qualche modo collegati,
e che il problema dei semi
è al centro di questi problemi.
Parlare di semi significa
fondamentalmente parlare di salute,
c'è stato qualche accenno già quest'oggi.
Perché tutto il cibo che noi mangiamo,
di fatto, direttamente o indirettamente,
proviene da semi,
e siamo tutti d'accordo, credo,
che la nostra salute
dipenda da ciò che mangiamo,
particolarmente oggi
che è stato dimostrato
che molte delle malattie moderne
in realtà derivano dal cibo.
Tornando al cambiamento climatico,
una cosa che non si dice,
o si dice molto raramente,
è che noi in realtà non sappiamo
di che cosa parliamo,
perché nessuno oggi è in grado di dirvi
quanto più caldo farà e quanto meno
pioverà a Como fra 20 anni.
Associato al problema
del cambiamento climatico
c'è quello della biodiversità,
e qui c'è una grande contraddizione
nella scienza moderna,
perché da una parte,
se voi sfogliate i numeri
delle riviste più importanti,
tipo Science e Nature,
quasi ogni settimana,
sicuramente ogni mese,
ci viene detto che la biodiversità
è la chiave per la sicurezza alimentare;
e dall'altra un'altra scienza,
il miglioramento genetico,
che quegli alimenti producono,
è andata in maniera esasperata,
negli ultimi 20-30 anni,
verso l'uniformità, in direzione
esattamente opposta.
Pensate che oggi quello
che voi comprate al mercato,
i cavolfiori, le zucchine,
i pomodori e i peperoni,
tutta quella roba lì, per essere
legalmente commercializzata,
quelle varietà devono essere
state iscritte a un registro,
che si chiama registro delle varietà,
e per essere iscritte a quel registro
devono essere uniformi,
stabili e riconoscibili.
E immagino che la contraddizione
tra uniformità e stabilità,
e la necessità di adattarsi
ai cambiamenti climatici sia palese.
Contemporaneamente, sempre
negli ultimi 20-30 anni, forse 40,
si è assistito gradualmente
a un consolidamento
di un vero e proprio monopolio
nel mercato mondiale dei semi,
un mercato che vale miliardi di dollari
e che oggi, per il 65% circa,
è controllato da quattro grosse
corporazioni internazionali.
Che cosa significa controllo del seme?
Significa che quando
l'agricoltore va al mercato,
a comprare i semi per seminare,
non ha grandissime scelte.
Negli Stati Uniti oggi
è pressoché impossibile
- io ho appena scommesso 50.000 euro -
trovare seme di mais
o di soia che non sia
geneticamente modificato.
Questa ridotta possibilità
di scelta, da parte dell'agricoltore,
su ciò che può seminare
si ripercuote sulla diversità
di ciò che lui coltiva
e sulla diversità del cibo
che noi mangiamo,
e questo è associato a tutta
una serie di malattie
e ci fa pensare se siamo veramente
noi a decidere che cosa mangiamo.
Accanto a questo monopolio
del mercato dei semi
si è sviluppato il monopolio
nel mercato dei pesticidi,
a cui si è fatto cenno
anche questa mattina.
I pesticidi sono abbastanza interessanti,
perché i medici ci dicono
che, tra le 12 sostanze chimiche
più pericolose al mondo,
nove sono pesticidi,
e alcune di queste
corporazioni internazionali
che vendono semi
vendono anche pesticidi.
Allora diventa logico chiedersi:
ma se io vendo semi e pesticidi,
perché dovrei vendere
semi che danno piante
che di pesticidi non hanno bisogno?
E tutto ciò, probabilmente,
finisce in quel piatto.
Come siamo arrivati
a questo punto?
L'evoluzione del miglioramento genetico,
di quella scienza cui accennavo prima,
ci può aiutare a capire.
Il primo speaker di questa
mattina parlava appunto
dell'uomo del Neolitico,
10-12.000 anni fa,
che, a cominciare dalla Mezzaluna fertile,
quell'arco che va
da Giordania a Palestina
e Israele, Siria, Libano,
il sud della Turchia
e poi giù giù verso l'Iraq,
- lì è cominciata l'agricoltura.
Io ho lavorato per 30 anni
in un istituto vicino ad Aleppo,
e i semi di orzo più vecchi
sono stati trovati dentro delle giare
e in un villaggio a circa 100
chilometri da Aleppo,
oggi sommerso dalle acque dell'Eufrate.
Lì, l'uomo ha addomesticato
- perché anche le piante possono
essere addomesticate,
non con i metodi con cui
si addomesticano gli animali
ma semplicemente le piante selvatiche
lasciano cadere i semi a terra.
Le piante diventano addomesticate
quando, per mutazioni spontanee,
trattengono i semi di una spiga,
e la donna, probabilmente del Neolitico,
ha afferrato immediatamente
l'importanza di queste piante strane
che non lasciavano cadere i semi a terra.
E lì, in quella zona,
nella Mezzaluna fertile,
questo è successo per il frumento,
per l'orzo,
per la lenticchia, per il cece,
per il fico, per il pistacchio
e altre specie.
Questo poi è successo in altre parti
del mondo, per altre specie.
Poi che cos'è successo?
Che a partire da 9000 anni fa,
questa gente ha cominciato a emigrare
- la Turchia, la Grecia, poi i Balcani -
sono entrati in Italia dalla frontiera
est, circa 7000 anni fa,
e a un certo punto si fermavano.
E questo lavoro
di miglioramento delle colture
è continuato per circa 9000 anni,
e ancora oggi -io l'ho visto in Nepal,
l'ho visto nel nord dell'India-
prima di raccogliere si va al campo,
si scelgono le piante più belle,
quel seme viene conservato
in un angolo fresco e asciutto della casa,
verrà riseminato l'anno successivo
e il resto si raccoglie, si mangia
o si da da mangiare agli animali.
Ora immaginatevi questo lavoro,
fatto da migliaia di agricoltori,
in tantissimi posti del mondo,
con tante culture diverse.
Ognuno ovviamente selezionava
per quello che noi chiamiamo
adattamento specifico,
cioè selezionava le piante belle,
in quel particolare terreno,
con quel tipo di pratiche culturali
e per l'uso che faceva di quella cultura.
Quando voi sentite parlare
di vecchie varietà, di cereali antichi,
è da questo lavoro
di millenni, che vengono.
Poi, con la riscoperta
delle Leggi di Mendel,
poco più di 100 anni fa,
il miglioramento genetico ha avuto
un grosso cambiamento,
nel senso che tutto ciò
che fino a quel punto
era stato fatto da tantissime persone
in tantissimi posti del mondo,
ha cominciato ad essere fatto
da relativamente poche
persone, i ricercatori,
in relativamente pochi posti,
le stazioni di ricerca,
e c'è stato un grosso cambiamento
di filosofia della ricerca,
perché mentre gli agricoltori
selezionavano per adattamento specifico,
il ricercatore ovviamente
non poteva fare varietà
per la stazione sperimentale,
le doveva fare per il mondo esterno.
E quindi cercava di selezionare varietà
che andassero bene
per quante più persone possibili.
Questo ovviamente ha determinato
la scomparsa, in parte,
delle vecchie varietà,
ha prodotto una grande uniformità
e soprattutto è una filosofia
che è alla base
della cosiddetta agricoltura industriale,
che non può fare a meno della chimica,
perché queste varietà, ovviamente,
bene dappertutto non potevano andare,
e allora, laddove non andavano bene,
si modificava l'ambiente
con concimi, antiparassitari,
pesticidi, acqua di irrigazione,
in modo che anche quell'ambiente
potesse andare bene per quella varietà.
Questo, per inciso, andava bene
anche alle industrie sementiere
che nel frattempo stavano sorgendo,
perché per l'industria sementiera
è molto più conveniente
vendere tanto seme di poche varietà
che poco seme di tantissime
varietà diverse.
Io ho cercato di ribaltare
un po' tutto questo,
con un metodo di miglioramento genetico
che pur utilizzando
la stessa identica scienza,
anzi tutti i requisiti
della scienza più moderna,
riportava il miglioramento genetico
nelle mani degli agricoltori.
Questo modello si chiama
miglioramento genetico partecipativo,
non sono soltanto io a farlo,
e fondamentalmente
introduce tre cambiamenti.
Per prima cosa, tutto il lavoro
si fa nei campi degli agricoltori;
gli agricoltori partecipano
a tutte le decisioni
- io, quando arrivo in un posto
in cui non sono mai stato,
la prima domanda che faccio
agli agricoltori è:
quali sono i vostri problemi?
E la terza differenza
è che questo modello
si può applicare
in tantissimi villaggi diversi,
soltanto in funzione
di quante risorse voi avete.
Il pallino giallo è dove io
ho lavorato per 30 anni,
quelli blu sono le stazioni sperimentali
del Ministero dell'Agricoltura siriano,
e i rossi sono i villaggi.
Ecco, qui il punto chiave
è che ogni villaggio
diventa un'unità
di selezione indipendente,
cioè lì si seleziona
ciò che va bene in quel villaggio,
selezionano uomini e donne,
il metodo ovviamente è molto inclusivo,
e si fanno varietà
specificatamente adatte
a quel particolare luogo, a quel
particolare modo di coltivare.
Questo modello
io l'ho cominciato in Siria nel '95,
poi gradualmente è stato
implementato in Marocco,
in Tunisia, Algeria, Egitto,
Etiopia ed Eritrea, Yemen, Iran,
e può arrivare e può
essere utilizzato in posti
dove il miglioramento genetico cosidetto
convenzionale non è mai arrivato:
questo progetto su orzo e lenticchia
nelle montagne dello Yemen
- tutta l'agricoltura dello Yemen
è praticamente in queste terrazze,
costruite 2000 anni fa,
che non sono mai state raggiunte
dalla scienza convenzionale.
Poi, all'incirca intorno al 2007-2008,
ci siamo accorti che questo modello
aveva un punto debole,
e il punto debole era proprio
nella collaborazione necessaria
di una istituzione,
perché le istituzioni,
nei confronti di questo modello
che di fatto riportava molto potere
nelle mani degli agricoltori
- a molti governi questa cosa
non andava giù,
per cui nel 2008 io ho rispolverato
una vecchia idea
di un ricercatore americano
che si chiama miglioramento
genetico evolutivo,
che consiste nel fare
dei grandi miscugli.
Questo che vedete
è uno coltivato in Sicilia,
io questa cosa ho cominciato
a farla in Siria nel 2008,
poi noi siamo venuti via nel 2011,
e questo è un miscuglio,
vi prego di credermi sulla parola,
di 2000 tipi diversi di frumento tenero,
il frumento con cui si fa il pane.
Che cosa succede?
Che in questo miscuglio avvengono sempre
un po' di incroci tra queste piante,
per cui il seme che voi raccogliete
non è mai geneticamente identico
a quello che avete seminato,
cioè la popolazione
gradualmente si evolve.
E si evolve in che direzione?
Nella direzione di diventare
sempre più adatta,
adattata a quel particolare ambiente,
a quel particolare modo di coltivare,
e quindi si adatta bene all'agricoltura
biologica e biodinamica,
e soprattutto, se vi ricordate
quello che ho detto all'inizio,
sarà adattata al clima
che ci sarà tra 20 anni,
senza sapere oggi quanto più caldo
farà, e quanto meno pioverà,
perché ha tutto il tempo
per, appunto, evolversi.
Questa idea, in questo momento,
è attuata in Giordania, Etiopia,
in Iran queste popolazioni
[si] stanno diffondendo dappertutto
e nel 2009-2010 sono arrivate
anche in Italia.
Sono tre popolazioni:
una di frumento duro, per il pane;
una di frumento tenero,
per la pasta, e una di orzo.
Sono in questo momento coltivate
in circa 14-15 regioni italiane.
Gli agricoltori iraniani hanno fatto
una scoperta interessante,
che adesso stiamo attuando
anche in Italia,
e cioè hanno fatto il pane direttamente
con la farina di questi miscugli.
E hanno scoperto che dopo 6 mesi
che questo pane stava in commercio,
non solo era molto apprezzato,
perché aveva un profumo
e un aroma straordinari,
ma questi panettieri
hanno cominciato a ricevere
telefonate dai clienti che dicevano,
ma che cosa ci avete messo in quel pane?
Perché in questo villaggio,
tutti coloro che soffrivano
di intolleranze
da quando hanno cominciato
a mangiare quel pane
si sentono molto meglio.
Noi stiamo facendo ancora
questa esperienza in Italia,
particolarmente nelle Marche, dove io
in genere vado quando vengo in Italia,
e quindi stiamo dimostrando
che con questi miscugli
non soltanto abbiamo una tecnologia
per adattare le colture
in modo dinamico e poco costoso
ai cambiamenti climatici,
non solo si riporta
biodiversità nei campi,
perché ovviamente queste
popolazioni si evolvono
in modo diverso nei diversi posti,
non solo si riporta il controllo dei semi
nelle mani degli agricoltori
ma si produce un cibo
che è molto più diverso
e, come ho detto prima,
diversità di cibo
significa maggiore salute.
Grazie.
(Applausi)